there was nothing out of the ordinary
about this review he got a
middle-of-the-road rating and I you know
I told him these are things that you do
really well there's some things that you
do need to work on one of them was that
he spent a lot of his workday
socializing very rarely did I actually
find him at his desk I just made a note
of that
couple months go by he went to HR and
made a claim that I had sexually
discriminated and I had propositioned
him and like had offered to take him to
strip club in the city and I'm just kind
of like wow I don't even know where this
is coming from HR had to go through
their process they went through their
entire review they didn't dismiss it
they instead said what we found was that
you tend to use a lot of course language
with people
you swear lie we're putting you on a
performance improvement plan I was so
afraid that I could walk into HR
following Friday and find myself being
fired I'm a fundraiser for a non-profit
school so I work with private donors to
raise money for our scholarship program
one night after an event I was sitting
with my employer and with the host of
the event who was a longtime major donor